I was what I think is now called a
digital Nomad for quite a few years and
over time just having stuff was really
inconvenient and so over time I just had
less and less stuff to the point where
like all my stuff fits in that backpack
at this point that is across from us in
this recording studio yeah I just I just
don't have a lot of stuff so hold on a
second so does this exclude or include
clothing so I have this pair of pants
this is my only pair of pants okay I
have three shirts I have 10 pairs of
underwear I have 10 socks
that's it so you must have tried a lot
of pants and shirts then what are we
working with here these shirts are
definitely quality these are
the Calvin Klein
modal is the material yeah they're super
breathable they don't get smelly yeah
these are great the pants are
ones that my wife picked out so I don't
actually know what they are that's great
yeah they made the cut they did or or
maybe there's some karmic debt and you
have to just have to wear them now
they're they're honestly they're a bit
too thin and so whenever it gets hot I
feel like I'm glued to them and it's
very hard to take them off but yeah
okay all right so we'll stick with the
shirt recommendation what else is in
your bag
is there anything that wouldn't be
obvious I'm sure there's a laptop and
some cables some charging Etc you have a
lot more cables than than you would
anticipate there's a like six or eight
different cables that I have to do to
connect things dongle City yep I have
you know standard toiletries I think one
that I I keep with me that's maybe a
little bit uncommon throwing stars no I
keep I keep some with my my I call them
my focus goggles okay they're kind of
like horse blinders so when you're on an
airplane I I have the attention span of
a goldfish and so if I'm trying to work
and the person next to me is watching
Transformers I'm just gonna end up
watching Transformers with no sound and
so having these just blocks my ability
to see anything for affili I have them
here if you want to check them out would
you mind just yeah I want to see these
things
I might need a pair of these
here why don't you sit down just so
people can see this because this is also
not a big bag No this is substantially
smaller than my bag which does not
contain all of my Earthly belongings
these are my focus goggles oh wow you
made these oh yeah customers this is
incredible okay so what we got here
these are okay so for people I'm gonna
put these on in a second but for people
who can't see them so they're basically
almost like glasses they're like
shooting range glasses you have
basically created
like Inuit style sunglasses in a sense
yeah which people can look up but by
painting something on the surface to
create sort of a thin sliver it's like I
took a little bit of masking tape over
the middle this is the third iteration
okay put some math name in the middle I
spray painted and then you spray paint
it and then you put like kinesio tape or
something yeah that's just like a normal
athletic tape because I've been trying
with the the spacing wow yeah these are
pretty amazing yeah and so they're good
I've tried different versions so like
one of the versions yeah I was imagining
actual blinders which would be a little
yeah it might freak out the families
around yeah I mean this also freaks
people out
that is amazing yeah it's okay it's it's
the perfect we'll definitely need a
photo of this this might be I think this
should be for the thumbnail for the
episode you should have these on that
would definitely get a couple of extra
clicks yeah all right those are cool
this is a third version the first
version was just dots just circles but
turns out with that form fact after you
get really dizzy that sounds awful yeah
it's bad so doing the slit works but
then it turns out this slit was a little
bit too wide so I just put some tape on
it but this is this is the final form
yeah of the focus goggles
okay focus goggles for the win
anything anything else you got in there
any like runes that you cast to make
critical company decisions
I keep my passport
I'll keep a copy of the constitution in
my bag okay tell me more it's the law so
it's a good reminder don't break the law
again don't break the law again no
seriously what is it I mean I understand
it's the law but yeah
most people also don't want to
inadvertently or purposefully break the
law but they don't carry a copy of the
Constitution so what what what does that
serve you know in your life it's
surprising it takes like two hours to
read it it's a really short document
and it is surprising how often it ends
up coming up in a discussion or a debate
like one recently related to the
election somebody was saying the
Electoral College is unconstitutional
and he said no no it's in the
Constitution it's article two section
one they're like no no it's not it's
like I have a constitution right here
and there I go okay fine yeah it was
definitely it's literally in the
Constitutions definitely constitutional
like okay well it shouldn't be
constitutional it's like fair enough
yeah but like it's definitely
constitutional
foreign